[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
nicolas et pimprenelle font beaucoup de
bruit ce soir j'ai bien l'impression
qu'ils sont en train de se disputer
je descends voir ça pas trop j'ai peur
qu'ils le fassent des bêtises on le
jeune je te dis qu'un nom mais en fait
nicolas tu sais ce que maman il faut
ranger tout ce désordre et gtc ville à
cayuga ramenait du jardin non et non je
les garde
ils sont pas moi je vais les cachets sur
la chemise personne ne trouvera bonsoir
les enfants vous en faites du bruit
vous ne vous disputez pas au bout un
dossier qui ne discutent pas regular de
oui je vois que vous ranger vos affaires
oui nos tounes de rage tout mais tu dois
pas touché sur la cheminée au je vais
pouvoir et on on ne touche à rien puis
vas-y le dour ce qu'est ce que ce que ce
soit ça c'est un secret est je le
cachais email à ses bras yep et fier
bravo pas brunel mais que fait donc ton
frère dans la salle de bain nicolas
nonon nours ne venait pas
ou est-ce que je peux bien les cacher
alors qu'attend on va lui faire une
bonne blague
nicolas qu'est ce que tu veux on te
demande au téléphone c'est un copain
nicolas pina tendrement ce taux est que
monsieur nicolas il arrive je viens
merci limoges allô allô allons les
enfants donne moi c'est qu'elle joue pas
prodel la merci et maintenant ou de dos
moi je sais ce que je veux enfin de ses
quinze jours
alors qu'ailleurs nous
je m'occupe nicolas jeu mode bonne nuit
les petits faites deux tours
base nominaux demain
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants
j'espère que vous faites comme nicolas
et pimprenelle que vous ranger bien
chaque soir vos affaires avant d'aller
vous coucher
il faut toujours remettre tous vos
joujoux à leur place mais qu'est ce que
tu fais nounours comme vous patron je
sais moi je sais de cailloux comme le
petit poucet allons en route
petit poucet à demain les enfants fait
de pur
où
[Musique]